okay everybody this is my spoiler review
of the new netflix series the sandman
this was one of my most hyped up shows
for the year i actually read the comics
the whole series for the first time last
year to prepare for this and kind of get
in the zone all about the story of the
sandman and i'm gonna put a first
disclaimer here that will probably tune
people out right away from watching this
video but
after reading the whole comic series i
think it's one of the most overrated
stories i've ever read and i'm actually
saying that in the sense of i still
really enjoyed it i could see why it's
praised as being a brilliant piece of
work but in the part of engaging me
bringing me in and keeping me hooked and
excited for what's next like turning
pages the sandman graphic novel series
did not do that for me i think that the
sandman to me is the best
in the comic book series when it says
self-contained stories i thought those
were incredible to the hype but the
overarching story in the sandman series
never really engaged me or brought me in
and that i want to say before i get into
my review about the show because i still
felt a lot of those same feelings with
the show because it is still
mostly the same story that overarching
story where i prefer
things like the cat story in the comics
or the tales of the sand or even what we
get to see which was the best episode is
the 24 hour story from the comics but i
have a lot of thoughts here and with
this show it's interesting because
i think they got a lot right and there
was a lot here to enjoy and you got some
really good actors in this but there's
really two critical things that
really kept the show from going the next
level for me the first is the casting
and
that's only with two people where i
think they got it right with everybody
else but two people and that's with the
sandman himself and lucifer now the
reason i'm saying it with the sandman i
want to get into first is that dream
when you're reading the comics or just
the look of him he's very cold he has
this darkness in his soul to him he
literally has black eyes
now
they did not go with the black eyes
which i can understand which is kind of
hard to do in just a character and tv in
general and keeping that up but
maybe they should have here because the
actor tom sturridge is a really good
actor it's not him that's a problem in
his acting it's who they cast it it's
just how he looks meaning he gives off a
friendly demeanor to me too friendly
like i don't see darkness in his soul i
don't see brokenness i just see
a really nice guy you know i think he'd
play a great harry potter when he was
younger he's that person you don't want
daniel radcliffe playing the sandman
holder right so i feel like it was
criminally missed cast and the people
were like well he looks just like neil
gaiman neil gaiman had a lot of
inspiration for the sandman off of
himself which is true but the artist and
the sandman with neil gaiman as looking
like the salmon but it still was a way
darker version neil gaiman not neil
gaiman himself so that's where i get
frustrated where it kept taking me out
of it that he just is not giving me that
commanding presence that's also this
thing where he enters the room like in
the comics you feel oh my god dream is
here what is he gonna do that did not
happen here it just felt like he was one
of the crew in this show and that really
disappointed me and again just seemed
too friendly it's just his demeanor it's
just a miscast it's nothing against the
actor in my opinion that was a big
criticism the other one was the casting
of lucifer like i said with gwendolyn
christie who i'm a huge fan of from game
of thrones i think that
again
just a total miscast where
i feel like her as an actress she has a
certain range certain characters she's
perfect for like bran of tarth or even
in the star wars series as captain
phasma she's just commanding force but
she's also someone who is not someone
who's like this character that needs
that full kind of charm there and that
devilish side literally for a lucifer i
never felt like she was right for this
part just from the minute she got on
screen i didn't feel like i was watching
just lucifer like this is a role you
kind of want to have a little more fun
with you want to be commanding but you
also want to just embody hell right
embody lucifer you're the devil for for
christ's sake you know and i felt like
she brought nothing to that i felt like
it was just gwendolyn christie just
doing what she does best which is you
know being this powerful force but she's
also more comes off as like a loyal
honorable person and maybe that's in my
head being just so used to bran of tarth
but i did not feel lucifer vibes here at
all and that really was disappointing to
me and on the topic of lucifer there's
moments too that are it's a really hard
comic to adapt to screen and maybe the
battle between her and sandman just a
little
like corny to me it didn't come off
amazing them naming different things
fighting each other just didn't work and
again it's such a hard comic to adapt to
tv because the comic you feel like
you're in a dream there's so many
amazing visuals so it's tough to pull
off and that's where my second big
criticism of the show is the option they
did with the camera because they do a
lot of out-of-focus background blurry
effect on the edges kind of like trying
to sell it as like a dream like effect
but it also to me is just hiding they
didn't have enough money to kind of fill
in the background and make it look
amazing like it might be in the comics
and that's a budget thing but it's also
you know you could take off that filter
in other scenes where we're just in a
diner for example it's too much like i
thought it was just taking away from the
quality of the image in general i want
to see a picture-perfect image for a
show like this and i thought that was
just a terrible choice how they kind of
did the cinematography with the out of
focusness just used too much here it was
just distracting and took away from it
now with all this complaining and things
i didn't like there's a lot to like here
i think that
obviously you're crazy if you don't
agree with this statement but david
thulis stole the show here and he did
amazing as john d from top to bottom
those are the scenes i was on the edge
of my seat and also in the book
in the first volume those were the
scenes i was on the edge of my seat so
kind of lined up where i was actually
having more fun away from the sandman
and what was going on in other stories
and really impressed by how they did the
24-hour episode and that
it was gripping and you kind of honestly
just watched that as its own movie you
could just play that episode and it has
great writing in it and that's props
obviously no gaming but
really david thulis just kills it there
every actor in that episode and that
it really could just be like i said
those great sandman self-contained
stories in a sense even though sandman
always gets involved one way or another
that
it's something you could just throw on
without knowing anything about the show
and really enjoy it and i thought that
was the standout of the season that was
to be expected because that was a
standout chapter to me in the whole
series that was my favorite chapter and
it gets really dark i think they went
almost all the way there it wasn't
perfect like you know it wasn't like a
masterpiece episode i think there's
still something a little flat about all
this but it was really good and i
thought they did a good job with that
and again david lewis just stole the
show here and what i did like though is
that we knew he was gonna leave
eventually and i was wondering how the
final episodes would fill out but i
actually really loved the actress of
rose walker i thought she was great i
thought some of the story with her was
really good but then i thought the final
two episodes got a little flat again but
most of it worked for me especially
because we got also great other
appearances and castings like the
corinthian i thought was great i thought
obviously stephen fry's gilbert was
great i thought patton oswalt as the
raven matthew awesome it was perfect and
then marvin we got a little bit of mark
hamill which was really good i thought
lucian was excellent and i also thought
death was excellent i think kirby hal
baptiste has the perfect aura for that
part there's a little charm there she
gets the character of death so i think
that was really exciting to see again in
all of this when i'm finding these notes
i'm like oh they nailed that they nailed
that actor it's just still i'm just
sitting there wishing like oh if they
just had someone play dream that was in
that like christian bale vibe of that
coldness like look how christian bale
was perfect for the role of someone like
gore where there's that coldness to him
the soul broken we need that that's part
of the salmon to see this man change
transform we can't just have him be in
this nice you know friendly looking guy
so that was
could not get out of that in my head
which was bringing it down for me but
when i look at my scores for the whole
season episode by episode
most of them are in the
eight range and a good amount also in
the seven range that's kind of where it
falls so i averaged all my scores out
and it actually hit eight on the nose
for me this season i think the best was
in the middle and again with the 24 hour
chapter in the beginning of rose
walker's story i thought was the best of
the show i think some stuff was a little
flat also even joanna constantine's
story with jenna coleman it still felt
like the look of it was like maybe the
lucifer show on netflix which is from
the same universe of the sandman but it
had too much of that where i wanted a
little more you know different looking
more bigger budget looking where again
it just felt like another those kind of
adaptions it's like okay this is just a
tv show doing something that's way
better that's in the comic form but
that kind of just didn't really wasn't
amazing i think throughout the whole
show i was sitting there it had me i was
interested but i was never again besides
that 24-hour thing i was never really on
the edge of my seat or just excited to
go the next episode and really engaged
in but maybe i'm biased too because like
i said i wasn't really totally engaged
in the comics either so please keep that
in mind too maybe you were on the edge
you see your whole time with this i'd
love to know but that also is a
christmas to the score here too that
that to me felt like very a harry potter
score mixed with like lock and key if
you heard the score for that on netflix
where it's a little too happy for me my
taste for salmon in my head like when
i'm reading the comics i'm not imagining
like
to do like through the show so that felt
offbeat and tone too so
strange but i'm interested to see where
it's gonna go it's interesting they
nicely stopped it at the end of volume
two here with the roses store was a good
place to hit i think they plotted it
well to have these two volumes be the
first season i think that makes sense i
think that i wish we could have saw the
sand story in there that would have been
really cool but i get it it's hard to
kind of just put a self-contained story
randomly in a show season because you
kind of will stop momentum of the whole
show it's not a comic so you got to
change some things up we'll see if they
do the cat thing i love the cat story if
you haven't in the comics definitely
read the next volume to get that cat
story it's one of my favorites i hope we
actually get to see that but i won't be
surprised if we don't i get it but
overall for me this show i'm going to
take away is that david doulas is the
peak of it
he was awesome i love the 24 hour
episode i like the beginning of rose
walker's story there's a lot of good
casting here mostly got it right but
it's just hard when you had the most
important character to get right in
dream just it was just a miscast and it
really brought this down for me and
again with the blurry filter everywhere
the out-of-focus backgrounds just didn't
work for me visually but i still think
it's a solid outing and it's a tough
task to pull off the sandman comics as a
show so i think it has potential to have
a way better season two and i think that
there's a lot of good groundwork here
and maybe consider you know giving tom
sturridge to black eyes doing something
to make him a little more intimidating
and really feel like the lord of dreams
here so i'm giving it an eight let me
know what you thought i'd love to hear
other thoughts please everything every
casting every episode what you thought
i'm really interested because there's so
many thoughts i have going on about this
but i want to see how it lands with you
guys in particular the most so let me
know please subscribe if you enjoyed my
review here i do a bunch of reviews
movie reviews as well and i also do
celebrity interviews please follow me at
steve
on twitter instagram and tick tock for
more of me and i'll see you next time